you
good morning
our first order of business is approval
of the uh
the minutes from our march 18th meeting
are there any changes that need to be
done
i'll move the approval of the minutes
any changes
seeing none
well uh
please raise your hand
all those in favor
opposed
abstain okay
okay
uh uh
we have uh several items that have been
removed
fis22129
uh
fis22140
fis2241
fis22139
fis22148
fis22149
fis22150
fis22152
are there any other items to come off
seeing none could i have a consent
calendar
all those in favor of
approving the remainder of the consent
uh
and representative merchant just wanted
to give us a couple minutes on
what is actually going on
with
this item
uh
please
okay thank you thank you madam chairman
and also the rest of the committee
for giving me a couple minutes
at the february meeting there was a
discussion about the prescription drug
affordability board of creating an
account
within the department health human
services and at that time it was
requested to table because the rules in
place were not
promulgated
so i wanted to quickly give you folks an
update of where we are with the
rulemaking process um we are on track
we're hoping to have things finalized
and in time to get the gel car by the
august meeting and i gave a handout to
everyone
as far as the timeline there's any
questions on at this point in time we
are actively working on the rules we
have a draft before us we hope to
finalize that draft by the
april meeting which would be on april
25th
okay
thank you very much i appreciate it and
i appreciate all of the work that you're
doing to uh to get the rules thank you
okay we now turn to uh tab five
twenty 22 125
good morning for the record frank
edelblut commissioner of education
tammy vallancourt cfo for education
okay
um i do have just a couple of questions
i know that you had sent something out
but i wanted to
make sure that we all understand what is
happening with
the building you're in
and the building
that you vacated
because of asbestos etc
if you don't mind
no problem so not specific necessarily
to this i suppose although tangentially
related
so presently the department of education
is housed in three sites uh one is at 25
hall street which is the
granite state college building which
they have for the most part vacated
when granite state college was
assimilated into unh
they still occupy one floor in that
building
we rent space downtown in concord in an
office
tower there
and that is where our special education
bureau is housed right now because we
could not fit them into 25 hall street
and then we have several bureaus over in
the walker building at the state
most of the folks that have been
displaced are those who are at 25 hall
street at the granite state college or
in the downtown space
and formerly we were in lonergan
um where that project is uh so so we're
we don't actually manage because we
don't own the buildings that's managed
by des and i don't know if charlie wants
to weigh in on this or not but
my understanding is where we are in that
project
is that we have
mitigated the flooring
we have taken out asbestos in the
ceilings in that building and then those
will have to be replaced or put back in
and that is ongoing as well there's a
capital project to replace the restrooms
in that building and so that is going to
be scheduled while we're not in the
building so it's not as disruptive the
fact that we're out of there
that work is scheduled to be completed
sometime in late fall our lease at
granite state college which released
from the university system
ends on december 15th so we provided a
little bit of cushion there in case the
project runs longer than expected
and we're just you know we're just
watching that project unfold um and
we'll see where it goes
okay and um
actually can i mention one other thing
so because we were out of the building
in lonergan so the department of
education has been housed there for a
long time
um and so we took advantage of the fact
that everybody was out there to do a
full uh purging of that building and i
may not get these right so i'm going to
talk to tammy but
which included going through every
single document in that building we had
three 30-foot dumpsters that uh cleared
out stuff like we're talking attic stuff
everything
um
how many shredding trucks two
almost 200
200 boxes of shred of items that were
shredded they were um you know documents
that had pii on it so we cleared those
out um and and so basically the building
is completely empty at this point in
time um we also worked with the bureau
of archives as well as the state
librarian and we went through and
anything that had historical value we
preserved and um so i mean for example
we have educator records going back like
credential records from 1906 that we
preserved so okay
and um the the other question is i know
this is for air handling your 189
uh that was not included in the project
correct because the project was designed
principally around
asbestos mitigation
okay
and so
these dollars should cover your air
purification requirements
they should okay
thank you
uh could i have a uh
okay thank you sir uh
yes okay
roll calling 22 125
representative edwards
yes
coach
representative erf yes representative
all me
yes
senator daniels yes senator morse yes
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yes
representative umberger uh yes
man i'm sure the vote is 10-0 thank you
very much
is still in tab 5
welcome
good morning madam chair members of the
committee steve lavoy the director of
administration for the department of
safety and with me is new hampshire
state police sergeant chris storm who is
the oversees the unmanned aircraft
okay uh
someone have a question on this item
representative or senator rosenwald
thank you madam chair
um
as you know there's a
value of privacy
in this state that is important to the
public and the legislature
and i'm wondering if you could just tell
us what specific
guarantees
the public has that these drones will
not be used
in surveillance of private citizens
absolutely thank you for the question
privacy is is important
and it's something that's definitely
considered within our program um the
programs run in accordance with all
federal and state laws
and i'll pass it over to the sergeant to
give you more details about how that's
insured
thank you um so basically um could you
please state your name i'm sorry my name
is christopher storm and i work for the
department safety division of state
police um so we absolutely within our
policy um talk about the fact that we
will comply with all parts of article 1
part 19 of the new hampshire
constitution on top of obviously the
fourth amendment here in the united
states and
we even go a little bit farther in our
policy that if we are going to be doing
anything
as far as surveillance or anything like
that we will absolutely be apply for a
search warrant prior to doing anything
to do with surveillance
any exits and circumstances um we will
fall
obviously within the rules of that but
we take privacy very important we also
do not retain any of the information
unless it is needed for
prosecution so we will immediately get
rid of the the video or anything that
we've captured that we don't need
follow-up
this policy is it governed by statute or
rules or
just
so about policy
sure a little bit of everything we have
um stuff that absolutely curtails to
certain laws supreme court cases that
have come across due to surveillance um
we also have um we've gone a little bit
above and beyond that
back when representative um kirk was
here we sat down for a long time and
talked about the different um aspects of
what we would want to have in our
program back in 2017 when we were first
initially doing that and we sat down and
actually talked with him about
what kind of things would be needed to
be in place
are there any further questions
represent gaiden
thank you madam chair um thank you for
coming today
i would like to see a copy of a concise
uh compendium of the written policies
governing surveillance of private
citizens and businesses if that's okay
before i approve this in that we can't
put conditions on our votes
okay i'll be voting against this until
the receipt of such a document just to
representative
sorry
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair
so i i echo the concerns about privacy
i'm really glad that you guys have a
policy i'm looking forward to reading it
when you provide it to the commit
committee uh i
uh i'm curious how
uh what you considered to be a disaster
because the term is is the term disaster
defined somewhere on on when you can
um
is it defined i don't i don't know i'm
not sure if it is actually defined um
using that
to basically map any kind of whether the
disaster or
the
um could you speak into the marketplace
sorry yeah we're on youtube so people
need to hear you sure whether it's a
disaster or whether it's um something
that we're helping another state agency
map
say like a flood
all those different things we're using
them for mapping and to see the damage
and do damage assessment with them right
um is there an actual definition that
we've used or that i utilized to do that
i i don't think i did um
so i don't have a actual
definition for you
follow-up
follow-up so what you're picking up on
is is that
we have constituents who are extremely
concerned about their privacy and uh and
from a cynical perspective would like to
know exactly where the boundary
conditions are
do you think you're going to need an mou
with fish and games because that's
another big scenario with them out with
a lost hiker or something
so we already have been utilizing them
with fish and game to and
give you an example the other uh day
when uh the gentleman was missing up in
monroe um we were helping fishing game
um
for hours looking for um that that lost
gentleman
senator rosenwald
thank you
if we were to
table this item until we could see the
written policies would there be any
emergent
operationally i don't think so um
the
where the source that we're trying to
acquire these um uas is from um there
will be a price increase so that could
um that could be a problem um i know
they have a june 1st price increase
coming
so that could be that could be an issue
for us
well it's only april
senator daniels
thank you is there any reason why we
couldn't uh rent these as opposed to
um so
renting wasn't really considered as a as
a viable option because of the funding
source so these are federal federal
funds that have a grant period of
performance that have to be spent within
um the
two-year period of time um if we went
into a lease arrangement that could
exceed three five years and that would
shift these costs to to be state costs
so in this particular case it makes the
most sense for us to purchase these uh
we're also
not certain that there are a lot of
options to lease these
these aircraft because they are aircraft
they have to be registered
with the faa their
the liability and all the concerns
surrounding the aircraft are tied to the
owner and that brings up some unique
some unique challenges so
in this particular case the the purchase
option was chosen
follow-up
follow-up follow-up and uh
is there a reason why we can't use
manned aircraft
to do this
uh my understanding is that these
provide us with
these aircraft can can
fly at lower levels they can fly over
areas that manned aircraft
can't currently
they also can fly during conditions
that manned aircraft can't fly through
higher wind speeds
and it takes away that risk of of having
an individual in a dangerous situation
well let the sergeant expound on that
i would concur with all that the other
aspect of this is um a lot of the use is
for mapping um so those cameras we don't
have that kind of camera system either
on our fixed wing or on our helicopter
to help us map
serious motor vehicle collisions um
crime scenes
disaster as the other representative
brought up all of those things a lot of
these
uas's are used for photography and for
mapping
thank you
representative edwards
follow-up uh thank you um
so kind of a two-part question um
do you have visibility into how many of
these
are owned by our counties or other
government and
and like for example i know rockingham
county purchased one and our nursing
home has an mou with whoever purchased
it so that if a patient wanders off they
can use it to help find the patient so
so it just makes me wonder
is is is there sort of a inventory
visibility to where
not every state government agency needs
their own drone that we but we can have
a pool of them shareable
it's a great question i don't know how
many people actually have them it is
obviously an emerging technology that a
lot of people are utilizing
we were one of the the first groups to
have them
i don't know the answer to who has them
or if there is that ability to do that
we do have a a statewide
uas users group that allows any entity
to participate to see how there are
currently
due to covid we haven't met in quite
some time i would say there's probably
15 to 20 entities across the state that
were part of that so i'm sure there's
follow-up so it just makes me wonder if
um if we need sort of uh some
legislation to go with this next year
just to put somebody overall in the
state in charge of these drones so that
they can maintain an inventory and
manage a
an interagency sharing program because i
hate to see
us
buy in more drones than what we really
need just because everyone is stove
piped and doesn't see to the left or to
the right of them so
so i'm i i may want to come back to you
and ask you who the legit lead agency
for something like that might be
certainly
senator guida thank you madam chair uh
how many additional how many drones do
we have and how many additional will
this appropriation authorize the
purchase of so currently we have two
that we purchased back in
2018 was our purchase of them um
currently where um what the grant
applications applying for is 25 and it's
a different um
basically it's a different
platform use
back in 2017 we went with something
called the arion sky ranger which is a
much larger platform
that company was then purchased by a
company called flir
and then teledyne
and it is it's at its end of life um so
these are going to be a smaller um drone
that is uh far these are far more
capable and it will also allow us to
instead of having a central point right
now if um someone needs to utilize them
we actually have to drive to concord to
the hangar at airport road and then um
and then deploy from there um this will
give us the ability to have them in
a lot
of better distribution throughout the
state um it also allows us to be able to
be on scene quicker instead of people
waiting for us to do things
waiting for roads to stay shut down for
longer periods of time
waiting for our canines not to be able
to start a search and give them that
ability
so it's just a larger distribution and
each
pilot
that will be piloting these uh aircraft
will each be
uh have three they'll have a small
indoor option to help with our swat and
our tactical teams and then they'll have
basically a day and a night use and then
a solely a um one purpose mapping um
follow-up so with the current current
fleet of two
uh how how often do you deploy these
um i have do we have our
i would say
once to twice a week we're using them
for some something
in some realm
whether uh training whether a call for
service whether another agency asking
for help or within our own agency
um
in the situation in monroe i can tell
you we were up there flying at one point
and then we were down at the on the
everett turnpike
a a collision scene
within the same day so
it varies day to day
like i would echo representative edwards
interest in assimilating a centralized
group of these and using them
for other agencies around the state i
think because we will absolutely sense
yeah i didn't mean to interrupt you uh
we absolutely will and if anybody calls
us we won't say no to go help them
obviously
it's a it's a group effort to make sure
that this happens and if anybody needs
us or needs us to respond we're
absolutely coming to help them thank you
represent army
thank you
it sounds like they're going to be a lot
of people around the state making
decisions about whether something is an
emergency and is an authorized flight or
not is there any kind of chain and of
command in your policy
yeah yes ma'am um so um for the
the ability for these um aircraft to
deploy um it has to come through myself
to make that decision whether that's a
deployable um option we also have a
checklist um that absolutely tells us
when and when we can't um can't deploy
these type of aircraft um and then above
obviously above my pay grade we have um
bosses and so forth that are immediately
notified if that um that aircraft's
gonna fly um so if that aircraft's gonna
fly there's a page that goes out to our
command staff that says this is
happening
are there any further questions senator
rosenwald thank you um
not a question i'd like to move to lay
this on the table so that we can see the
written policy
do i have a second a second okay senator
ready
okay motion to table
motion table
22-129 representative edwards yes the
table
uh representative says yes represent
earth yes representative almi yes
senator daniels
yes senator morse senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald yes senator desandro
representative umberger
yes
madam chair the vote is 10-0 of the
table okay the vote's 10-0 to table
and um
as you know
um
we generally meet the third friday of
the month
so as soon as we can get that it would
be appreciated you'll have it today okay
i don't think there's anyone here that
is necessarily opposed to
the the drones but we just want to uh
make sure that we're
doing the right thing for our
people okay
uh thank you thank you
fis22141 in tab six
and this is also for the
steve
that's okay
me a trip thank you yeah
this is transfer of federal funds and
temporary full-time positions
senator rosenwald thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question
um your narrative says that
the department has taken on moral
responsibility and needs these
positions my question is
did these positions come up during the
budget process in either the house
or the senate when
you knew about the responsibilities
and did we say no
or did you not request them
uh thank you for the question these
positions did not come up during the the
budget process
um so we did not request them and nobody
has denied them the reason they didn't
come up is because at the time the
division of homeland security and
emergency management was was actively
engaged
in response to the covet 19 pandemic
and the eoc was fully activated
and unfortunately
while we submitted a complete budget
request
the time spent on long-term needs like
these
just wasn't available
to put forth these types of requests so
now that kovit has has the cove
emergency is is no longer in effect
the agency was able to reconsider their
structure especially given their their
responsibility since then and determined
that these positions were needed
yes
thank you for that explanation will you
be able to hire people
and if so
um will all departments come to you for
help
um we
we do believe we'll be able to hire
people homeland security has done a a
good job well we're all we're all
struggling with with vacancies and
hiring
the homeland security mission is is
something that we find people are
interested in supporting
and the director and her team have done
a good job in filling vacancies so we do
believe that there's a desire for these
particular positions and that we will be
able to hire them
homeland security is always available
and we'll be we'll be in that
coordinating position
as you know we are going to have a
d.a.s on hiring so
uh
any further questions
yes uh senator uh representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair uh this is a
little generic for the whole state but
since you're here i'm going to ask you
when we hire
new people off the street
into the temporary full-time positions
is there any encouragement that we do in
that process to have them sign up for
the 403 b instead of
our pension program
and if there's not
should there be so that we can start to
um i i think that's
it's that that's a good question um
at this point with our hiring challenges
that we have
we're looking to
hire individuals who are capable of
doing the job and aren't quite frankly
that focused on
transitioning one way or the other
i do think that i mean it's if it's a
statewide question it's probably an
administrative services response that
you'll be looking for and if you look
if you look over your shoulder
there we go um
but as far as in the department of
safety
all retirement options are provided to
the individual we don't necessarily
encourage them to go one direction or
the other we're providing them with all
commissioner i had a sense that i should
say hello uh charlie arlingham i'm the
commissioner of administrative services
on 403b which is some people think of as
the state's deferred comp plan
um
employees when they hire are encouraged
to consider the deferred complaint it's
a voluntary plan obviously
um and
[Music]
they're given information we're we've
started and i think we have 17 agencies
now doing a day one orientation and
actually craig downing the executive
director of the of the comp commission
um does a presentation at it to
encourage that and we're encouraging
more and more people to join
i i want to just caution about something
it's not instead of it's in addition to
it's like if you think if you know the
federal government the thrift savings
plan it's that kind of thing it's not an
addition to
in terms of the state retirement system
most of the people we're talking about
um
are not optional state retirees they're
mandatory state retirees they do not
have the option not to join the state
retirement plan system
whether they're um
in deferred comp or not but deferred
comp um we push it fairly aggressively
and at every hiring process um the 43 b
sorry
are there any further questions thank
you mr darlinghouse
seeing none could i have a motion please
senator d'alessandro moves do i have a
second
thank you senator rosenwald
uh
will the clerk please call the role on
fis2214
yes ma'am
representative edwards uh yes to pass
remember emmerich yes representative erf
yes
representative almi yes
senator daniels yes senator morse yes
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
we now move to tab 7
22 139
good morning chair this is patricia
tilley director of the division of
public health services at the department
and karen lucas formerly karen rounds
senator rosenwald you have a question i
do thank you good morning miss tillian
ms lucas
um
that's a lot to spring on us that's a
this is faulty testable
that's all
thank you um
i'm
wondering how good the data we're
getting from the pharmacies on
vaccinations is now
particularly if someone has traveled to
a pharmacy
in another state
um
because i know we were having trouble
breaking down the vaccination rate into
um first shot second shot
booster now second booster
how confident are we in
what our vaccination picture looks like
thank you senator rosenwald for that
question so things are getting better um
we have brought on our pharmacies within
the state of new hampshire from december
on they are giving us new information
from december on so that's great um you
know i think there is still some
question around how to count all those
boosters
and part of that is because
data the pharmacies sent their data as
we all know last summer and early on
directly to the federal government did
not send it to us when we send our data
to the federal government we actually
send de-identified data so there's no
way to match at that point so i know how
the number of vaccines that were given
i'm actually very quite confident in in
the number of doses that have been
administered in the state of new
hampshire it's less clear about how i
can tie that to an individual that they
received a first a second a first
booster and a second booster to
understand how many people may be fully
boosted at this particular time it beca
it gets even more complicated when
people received their vaccines in
multiple states my own daughter received
that you was in college so she received
part of her vaccination in in chicago
she received part of her vaccination
here it because we don't send that
identifiable data to
cdc it's hard to match we did some work
on our part to try and voluntarily get
that information from folks we did a
phone calling system and texting to
folks to say can you tell us you know it
looks like you didn't have a completed
series did you receive your vaccine
elsewhere again that was completely
voluntary but with any of those call
back processes you only get a small
perpet proportion of folks who actually
pick up the phone and ant you know that
are willing to answer in the first place
but pick up the phone and are able to
share their information
follow-up thank you so that doesn't give
me a lot of confidence but if i'm a
member of the public which i am and i
want to get a record of my own now for
vaccinations how do i do that
so you could do that in a number of ways
you can reach if you received your
vaccines through a state-run site
you know you went to one of the national
guard sites early on or to one of our
vendors
you can certainly call there's a way to
call the department of health and human
services and we will share back the
information for you with you if you
received your vaccines in a pharmacy um
we recommend people to not only call us
we we may have some of that data we may
not so it's good to go to the pharmacy
themselves and get that information from
the pharmacy directly or if you went to
your own private physician to get that
information this is why a vaccine
registry and having a complete and
consolidated vaccine registry is so
important because we know that many
people want to make sure that they have
all the information in one place and
that's where we're moving towards but
you know we know that there are pieces
because we were having so many different
ways that people got vaccinated
especially in those early days um that
it's it's not always as straightforward
just quick follow-up so if i lose my
card
and have gotten
one vaccination in
massachusetts at one pharmacy chain
and another one in new hampshire at a
different pharmacy chain
am i hearing that there will not be a
way for me to
get
that card replaced from the department
with
all the information on it i would
recommend in that in the case of that
scenario a person to call
the department of health and human
services we will see what we have um
available to us we know that
the cross-state uh vaccine has has
always been challenging and so the next
if if that information isn't fully there
we would give you recommendations of
where to go next of contacting each of
i thought i'd put some light on the
subject
great welcome representative edwards uh
thank you madam chair so miss tilly
would you uh address the the question or
the the concerns of the five to ten
percent of new hampshire's population
which will see more federal money going
into our vaccine program
and immediately worry about whether this
creates a new privacy risk or whether
we're going to be using this money to
force the vaccine on kids
thank you for that question
representative edwards we are not
forcing vaccine on anyone including
children we have um there is no school
requirement for covet 19 vaccine nor do
we anticipate that there will be
so that's a matter of choice for
families families should do what is
right for them and for their children
given their scenario their own
situations similarly for adults as a as
an adult in the state of new hampshire
no one the department of health and
human services is not requiring covid19
vaccine for anyone
i think to your other question of what
are these funds going to be used for
these funds are going to be used to
stabilize and enhance some of the
connections of the data system that we
have in place it will further support
that it's going to improve the data
quality that we have to answer senator
rosenwald's question it will give us
more manpower to be able to do you know
make sure all those historical data
pieces fit together
as well as moving forward that our data
is as strong and robust and secure as
possible and it's also going to allow us
to do things like purchase necessary
equipment like refrigerators and
freezers so that we can keep all our
vaccines safe so that when your child is
getting their routine childhood
vaccinations we know that that there is
a chain of custody that has been safe
and
you know that that is the appropriate
follow up uh so thank you for that as
you know from prior conversations those
are the kind of questions and
accusations i i tend to get so
kind of a long-standing theme
i've had in this committee is that
we
continue to see incremental additions to
our i.t budget and
one of these days i'd really like to get
around to having an entire discussion
focused on the i.t portfolio and all the
projects flowing into it and all the
money that's flowing into it because the
this one at a time kind of nature just
makes me worry a little bit about the
the department's visibility into the
entire
uh project portfolio that you you guys
must be carrying
so that that's again just another heads
up and i i think
hhs oversight is going to be asking for
something
thank you you know the only comment that
i would feedback is that we have been
working hand in hand across the
department
with our data governance and
understanding that this is that to your
point we've had siloed pieces of federal
funding supporting a larger system
i am confident that there is a
leadership team within the department
that is managing those resources and
ensuring that things are being
efficiently used and that they are
serving the
infrastructure of the department to the
degree that is possible as well as us
working hand-in-hand with do it thank
you
are there any further questions
seeing none could i have a motion
move the item
thank you represent earth do i have a
second senator rosenwald
roll on 22 139 representative edwards
yes to accept 139 representative emerick
says yes representative erf yes
representative almi yes
senator daniels yes senator morse
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes
madam chair the vote is ten to zero
thank you ten to zero the motion
promotion passes
we now turn to fis 148
governor's office
of emergency release
relief
oh
okay thank you
yeah thank you
i'm sorry
taylor castle here are we on go for item
yes we are all right thank you
which is uh the community college
expansion
for lpns
yes
would you like someone from the
community college to join you
um i'd be happy to
okay is uh mark here
someone is
no you turned it off thank you eileen
glover river valley community college
department chair for allied health okay
thank you
i understand there were some questions
that people had
senator rosenwald thank you my question
had already been answered but um maybe
only directly to me
and i just been wondering what
percentage of the graduates of this
program
stayed in new hampshire to work
and how we are tracking that
thank you part of our
data collection is to send out
postgraduate surveys and stay in touch
with our graduates to have them report
back
right now i would i don't have the exact
numbers in front of me i believe it was
prepared
um
that we have
i would somewhere between 85 and 95
percent of our graduates stay in the
state are from new hampshire and stay in
thank you are there any other questions
yeah representative
edwards
thank you madam chair i i think this is
a great program i'm looking forward to
voting yes
my question though is
what
do we do
to make sure
that
students that aren't currently enrolled
are aware of this
financial opportunity so that they can
use that information to go enter a
program i i just think there's a lot of
kids a lot of people
that would like to become lpns but if we
have this program they may not ever
become aware of it and therefore they
don't have the resources to go so how do
we connect the dots
that's fantastic thing to bring up we
our community college system workforce
readiness
workforce development work with our
community partners both in the high
schools the community education
technical centers
and
and other variety other ways to engage
and connect with not only young people
but people who are coming back into the
workforce to let them know about these
programs part of our
outreach and
development plans include all of that i
myself participate in workforce
development all over
the state and work with our partners to
make sure that the existing staff that
they have are aware of the support of
the clinical sites and of the school and
of the system to help people meet their
educational goals because the financial
burden is challenging for someone who's
trying to pull themselves up
and build a career who maybe was is
coming from a different
sector of the workforce or their first
are there further uh senator
d'alessandro thank you madam chairman
thank you very much
are there articulation agreements in
place that allow for these lpns to
transfer all of their credits into a bsn
program or an rn program absolutely so
river valley ourselves has a very clear
pathway for lpn to rn we're also working
with the other schools in the community
college system to help them develop
seamless pathways for our lpn graduates
into their rn program and then the
community college system itself has
articulation agreements with um all of
the four-year programs for nursing for
those who are interested in a
baccalaureate level education
just one further question
[Music]
and your
your program does an lpn get an
associate degree also
an lpn is a certificate program okay so
for the question how many credit how
many credits that are contained in the
certificate program 36 for this
particular program
okay thank you
are there further questions move the
item
represent all me
thank you i know that colby sawyer is
increasing its nursing program also i'm
not sure quite on is that a
bachelor degree colby sawyer is a
baccalaureate degree yes yes
and on
has an analysis been done of
the need at each level of nursing which
goes from
pretty much
cleaning up bed pans all the way up to a
phd
to so that we're training people on
to replace at the lower levels as well
yes i've been involved with the sector
partnership um in workforce development
and the the
constituents the group working to
increase entry level for l for lna the
licensed nursing assistant because that
is that's the entry level
and um
so there's there's groups out there
working on increasing visibility for
those programs to bring more people into
the pipeline and then once people are in
the pipeline
we work with them to help escalate and
help them meet their education goals for
each level there has been
data collected about each
nursing level and the need in the state
department of labor has done sector
partnership has done all of that
research and there is data out there to
support
the need for additional folks coming
into the pipeline
are there further questions
senator guida no ma'am just move the
item thank you do i have a second
enroll call in 22148 representative
edwards yes to 148
representatives representative erf yes
representative all me yes senator
daniels yes senator morse
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro
representative umberger yes madam chair
the vote is 10-0
votes 10-0 the item passes
thank you very much i appreciate your uh
coming in today
uh our next item is 22 149
and uh this is dealing with uh
the uh
judicial branch i
yeah for my next special guest yeah
for your next special guest that might
be able to yeah i think we do have
someone here from the judicial branch
versa
the hallway is a
big suck out there people go out there
and they don't come back so
and
great thanks
we know you are the font of all
knowledge
commissioner
but i think in this case it's probably
better
that um
the chief justice
talks
welcome
good morning madam chair members of the
committee uh the two items before you do
go together there is uh obviously the
item from gopher and then later on in
the agenda the item would you please
identify yourself i apologize only only
because
my name is gordon mcdonald thank you
i serve as chief justice of the supreme
court
um
broadly speaking uh these two items
together
will
help the state
make material advances
in addressing the long-standing
so-called emergency
room boarding crisis
last year the supreme court ruled
that
a uh
patient
for whom there is an invo voluntary uh
emergency admission petition filed again
must have a probable cause hearing
within three days of the signing
of the
certificate for admission
previously the hearings had been held
upon
the patient entering either new
hampshire hospital or a designated
receiving facility
what makes the change in law important
is now the hearings must be held within
three days
and
often those patients are in our local
emergency rooms waiting for a bed at
either the hospital or the drf
this crea creates a is
required reordering the way these
hearings were held
and basically the issue came down to
ensuring that the patients
and the attorneys who are appointed
receive notice on a prompt basis
the circuit court has
devised
and engineered a system to ensure that
these hearings are held within three
days
with the patient often in the emergency
room but that has turned into a very
very
intensive process
involving clerks
at many of our local circuit courts
working closely with hospitals and
clinicians
and as well as appointed counsel to
ensure
that the patient gets timely notice
and
and a hearing is held
i'm pleased to report that since our new
process has been implemented on march
21st there have been 176 hearings held
in only two
instances where the three-day deadline
was not met and there was a dismissal
and that is a dramatic improvement from
where we are
the issue for the circuit court however
is that this is not sustainable we've
had to divert both judicial and staff
resources to make this work
and the proposal in these two items with
before you is to create a
permanent sustainable system for uh
processing these
um
petitions
and essentially what it involves is the
creation of a statewide centralized
docket at the circuit court
to which we will devote two judges and
four staff
and they will handle on a centralized
basis
all iea petitions wherever they arise
around the state
and we will we believe this will help us
achieve
the statutory and indeed constitutional
mandate to ensure due process for our
patients
uh while also achieving frankly
efficiencies in the system instead of
having
eight separate circuit courts handling
hearings on any given day we're going to
be doing it in one place with a
specialized docket
so that manim chair is a summary of
these two items the gopher item provides
the funding for it and the judicial
branch item crete essentially creates
the two new judicial positions
if you remember members of the committee
i was before you we were before you in
january seeking the conversion of a
mayoral master position there does ex
exist authority within
statute for us to seek approval of this
committee to convert marital master
positions to circuit judges judge
positions so the judicial branch item
would
convert two marital master positions to
circuit judge positions to facilitate
the creation of our statewide mental
are there questions senator gaidan
thank you madam chair
uh chief justice good to see you
likewise how many of these iea petition
cases are there on an annual basis the
we estimate that the creation of the
stock will involve 2600 cases in and i
would
um
i think that's the right number 2600
senator
and that was it follow-up
thank you is that based on historical or
are there furthers
senator rosenwald thank you madam chair
good morning um there was a newspaper
story
this morning
saying that you had sent a memo to the
fiscal committee
about your pilot test and i i never
received it
um so
just wondering if you could
resend it i i'm wondering if there were
i don't know what the article said
but maybe perhaps it was referring to
the item that we submitted i don't know
but uh
it referred to a four-week pilot program
that you've been running and when i
reread the item
it didn't mention a four week program so
i thought perhaps there was
you're not the only one that didn't oh
okay
may i look track that down center thank
so uh
senator apparently there were questions
that came in to gopher
uh yesterday from the committee and i
believe in response to those questions
there was a memo that was submitted so
i'm
i got that correct
well
obviously it didn't get shared or if it
did it got lost in our inbox yeah you
received several emails from your
pre-fiscal questions so it would be a
response from um
gopher but you should receive that
yesterday afternoon it wasn't a
memo more of an answer to the questions
but
i'm not aware of any specific memo from
the judicial branch relative to that
pilot program um
but i can i can absolutely search my
inbox
okay for sure okay
senator daniels thank you
did i understand correctly that the the
funding requested in in 149 would at
least in part
pay for the new positions that you were
asking for
yes
okay
where
you are using one-time money through
opera to pay for this
with a notation that in the event that
federal funds are no longer available
general funds will not be requested
i thought i understood you to say that
you were you were looking for this to be
an ongoing thing so how is that going to
work
we would have to come and request
general funds
that's that's what's that's my point is
the notation says that you would not be
i think he what he's if if i might
that
he's not
with this but the startup of the program
he would not be requesting general funds
however for continuation of the program
which is down in fis 147
that would in fact be general funds
it's a request for general funds
and also
would be budgeted for
the future
but i
i'm not sure
if
the marital masters had had been funded
in the current budget
for 22 and 23
and that um
this would uh
not cost anything for the next two years
or the next year and a half
but would be um
budgeted in 24 and 25.
is that sort of right it's that's
oh
are there further questions uh
representative edwards
you both
came across the main question i had
given that we're going to be having to
budget for this in the out years could
we get a sense of what we're talking
about are we talking an extra million a
year to your budget a couple million
let's wait until we get to fis
22 146 yes ma'am okay that's that's
okay uh senator rosenwald's moves
approval do i have a second
will the clerk call the roll
roll call for 22-149 representative
edwards yes to 149. representative
emerick says yes representative earth
yes representative all me
yes
senator daniels
yes senator morse yes senator gaida
yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
man i'm sure the vote is ten to zero
vote being ten to zero this item passes
we'll look forward to seeing you in just
uh department of business and economic
affairs
and i notice he doesn't have a helper
with him this time
thank you madam chair i think maybe what
i might do if it's okay with you is just
to take one quick moment to
give an overview of uh this particular
item
which is a request to accept and spend a
little over 100 million dollars
to address the housing issues that were
housing issues we're currently having in
the state which i'm sure that you're all
acutely aware of
there aren't too many businesses in the
state right now that are not having
difficulty finding workforce
and this in particular uh is caused uh
increasingly by the lack of available
and affordable housing
and so this measure is designed to begin
to assist in the uh alleviation of those
problems by using uh this once really
once in a lifetime opportunity
to put this amount of money towards
this issue here in the state
we're currently looking at as you may
have heard last week a reduction of our
unemployment rate again to two and a
half percent
and the statewide vacancy rate for two
bedroom apartments right now in the
state is at point six percent
so that is very far from a healthy
environment for
available and affordable housing
so this uh these these there are two
main components to
the item that's in front of you
the first is with regard to
municipalities and their role in
in helping to move forward uh housing
initiatives locally
by giving them
some funding that would be associated
with the permitting of these rental
units in their communities
to the tune of ten thousand dollars per
unit that they would then be able to
have some flexibility in the use of
those funds whether it's for uh
you know items in direct relation to the
project itself or for anything else
that that the community may feel they
need to use those funds for
within that there are two other programs
one is regarding uh the
zoning process and the planning process
to assist communities that would seek to
have a review or an update of their
zoning regulations
that is a program that's currently
operates on a lower level uh municipal
technical assistance grant program
administered by new hampshire housing
finance authority
this
program would potentially be able to
improve the ability for that program to
provide those services
to communities without a match
to
understand what their
zoning options might be and what the
development options and how
projects are funded and how that process
goes i think that that would be
a lot of communities are welcome
a welcome uh
opportu resource
the last piece under the municipality
component has to do with the demolition
of
buildings that are no longer habitable
there are a lot of situations where we
have
uh projects either that are underway or
that would would be underway if not for
some older infrastructure that is
effectively in the way without the
resources to remove that structure so
that this program would be a grant
program that would be available
for those communities to take that
action
the second part
of the funding is really project
specific
this would be a total of 60 60 million
dollars 50 million of which
would be aimed at
a series of
um
eligibilities these would be
funds that would effectively be last
money in a lot of cases to a whole host
of different types of projects
those projects
would come
with a demonstrated need to be able to
establish a funding gap at the
at the far end of the development
process and so
just a quick overview would be that
these are for multi-family projects a
rental
component rental projects five units and
above
the funds would be used exclusively for
construction
or other hard costs that are associated
with the project
the project itself must add to the
housing stock that is available in the
community so
we wouldn't be doing a lot of
rehabilitation of existing units with
this with these funds
all the permits would have to be in
place
which sort of gets to my point of this
being further along in the in the
development process
and all the developers from the small
developers right on through
this would be a dollar for dollar match
program so any award that was made the
developer would have to demonstrate a
dollar for dollar match of investment in
that project themselves
there is a cap of three million dollars
per project
that is not going to always be a three
million dollar
grant that is the upper echelon of what
the project
would be able to take from this this
program uh we would invisib envision
probably uh regular
um regular funding rounds
uh over the course of the next year
through june of 2023
there would be
a requirement that the projects be
completed within 18 months
of
the of at least the funding
and lastly on that point i would say
an important one is that there are
eligibility requirements that we have to
contend with on the federal side of this
so
any of the funds that would be requested
would be only paid out in a reimbursable
basis after there was a review of
eligibility and
and appropriateness of the of the
requested funds to fit into what some of
the categories that i talked about there
there are obviously other details that
are going to need to be developed i
think this is a good sort of
overview of where we are right now
you'll recall a couple of months well
weeks ago now
we talked about some funding that would
be associated with the uh hiring of some
staff to come start administering and
making this program operational
we're in the process of getting those
uh into those jobs posted and hopefully
individuals into those jobs soon to sort
of start mapping out the final details
as it relates to what i just provided to
you so i think maybe i'll just stop
right there and if there's questions of
course certainly happy to try and answer
them
senator gaidan thank you madam chair and
thank you commissioner
for your testimony
several questions can you discuss the
federal eligibility criteria
so we would be
placing these funds into a bucket called
revenue replacement
which gives us some degree of
flexibility
but there are
certain restrictions on how the program
is used by the developer as it relates
to things like two cfr 200 and the use
of federal procurement rules
there are
a few other
eligibility
components that we would need to
consider
for all of these but the basic thrust of
it is that
of the
with the layout that i just provided you
that's designed uh to fit within the box
that we're we're designing we're working
with
follow-up
so
would it be safe to assume
dangerous word
that there are
requirements for certain income levels
appropriated with these projects
income levels of the project do you mean
no income levels of the tenants who will
populate these oh so um not within these
specific federal rules what the uh pro
what the program is designed to do
is to be able to help cover gaps again
near the end of a project
of a whole host of different types of
projects
most of those projects that we will see
and that will that will be eligible
coming forward will be projects that
already have some affordability
component built into it so in other
words they might be using low income
housing tax credits or they might be
using some other
public funded program through new
hampshire housing finance authority
those types of affordability
commitments would already be in place
for these fun and then these funds would
assist sort of get us over the finish
line
thank you paula
yes go ahead so you have any sense of
how many existing projects there are
currently that might be eligible
i don't have a good sense of that right
now i can only tell you that
my understanding my recollection is that
at least as it relates to projects that
are being administered by
the new hampshire housing finance
authority that there's around 1 500
units that are in construction process
right now
now whether that's a regular churn
um it's hard for me to say right at this
point but it's i would say it's at least
in that category
thank you very much
senator rosenwald
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my questions
um as i understand it we had two choices
for how to use this money the first way
would be to follow hud guidelines and
that would have required
that
the money be used to build affordable
housing for people whose incomes were up
to 300 percent of the federal
poverty level
or
take to use it as revenue replacement
um in which there are no
income there's no requirement for
affordability standards so
um
i'm wondering
why we chose not to build
affordable housing with these public
funds
and
and i i heard your previous answer that
some of the projects
that you think you'd be investing in
already have some income standards and
beyond that what are the specific
rails
that gover will have
to
assure us that this money will be used
to support affordable housing
and not
market rate housing and what specific
transparency measures will there be in
the process
thank you senator a couple of questions
there
i'm sorry
you might have to help me work through
them all so
on on your first question on the
transparency issue this program would
run um no different from any other
program that either gopher or ba has
administered where
there will be a great deal of
transparency as to where the funds are
and where they are where they go and
what they're used for
that would not be any different for this
program than any of the others
with regard to the affordability piece i
think it's important and i i acknowledge
the issue here i i think it's important
to to
to understand that what we're trying to
do with this fund is to create a
mechanism where we can accelerate
uh the number of units that are coming
online in the state as i mentioned
earlier at a point six percent unemploy
a
vacancy rate across the state uh that
a healthy vacancy rate is somewhere
between three and five percent
um i think it's you know when we when we
look at
how do we move those projects forward
quicker we're looking at projects
funding that comes late in the game
funding that is
flexible enough to be able to fit a host
of different projects so for example i i
had mentioned like the tax credit
programs that are out there if there's a
gap that this that is being seen at the
end of this project where they can't get
uh the project to move forward this
would be an opportunity for that project
to come forward get some additional
money
that would uh advance it um i think
uh to in to take
a situation where you already have
affordability commitments in place under
the rules and regulations the funding
that they're already getting under the
tax credit program and then layer that
on top of the subsidy that they're
already receiving either for the capital
for the operating cost
would not represent the most flexible
way to be able to
so that's one i think the other piece is
i
for the most part
and and we would see
a whole host of different types of
projects that would be coming
to this type of
program they would be as i mentioned the
affordable projects they would be
projects that have a zoning requirement
that might be enforced by a locality
like an inclusionary zoning requirement
they might be projects that have uh
mixed income within them so there's a
component that has an affordability
piece to it but then there's a market
rate component to that
um and they might be in a rural town
where you have um you know an old
victorian house that somebody's
converting into five six seven units
those are the types of projects that
would be eligible so trying to build a
program that allows us to get at all of
those different pieces
recognizing that the funds that we are
providing under this program are not in
and of themselves going to be the only
source of funding for any of these types
of projects
uh because the the cost of
of building these units far exceeds
anything that's close to a three million
dollar cap
so it's it's a it is as we say a capital
uh fund for f for gaps in these types of
programs
so i would just fall back on the point
that
this is designed to be as flexible as we
can
recognizing that i believe that the vast
majority of the projects that we are
going to see and in fact i'd be i'm i'm
anticipating that the first several
rounds of this program would be um
would be held
exclusively for our non-profit
developers who are developing
exclusively those types of affordable
units and for smaller units smaller unit
projects
that's the goal was the flexibility
component so i i hope i've
gotten at that a little bit
thank you
um
so of all the units that you believe
this money will help bring online
what percentage are you predicting will
meet that hud
guideline of
uh family income
up to 300 percent
i i i'm going to have to say it's
impossible for me to be able to say that
right now center exactly how many units
of which type we're going to have under
each category but as i stated there are
a number of considerations that any
developer is going to have to take into
account when they consider using these
types of funds
larger projects in particular are going
to fall within the realms of 2 cfr 200
where there are
procurement and other types of programs
that then would uh be applicable to
their project as a result of you
utilizing this funding so i think that
there's probably going to be some degree
of
self-selection that goes on
uh once this sits the actual marketplace
that we're looking to
influence
one final thank you
um are you aware that the disability
community has asked us to oppose this
project because
they don't believe it will
really result in affordable housing and
that people with disabilities are
disproportionately
impacted by the lack of affordable
housing
well i'm i'm not aware of of that
madam uh senator but i would say again
this
program is not designed to in and of
itself
be the sole source of funding for any
project that it is it is going to be an
addition
to multitude of other programs that are
already available and operating in the
state of new hampshire
for the purposes of affordable housing
for the purposes of housing for those
with melted illness those in an suv
situation
or homelessness funding those programs
are all still in existence
i think as a whole
when we look at the fact that we're
according to again new hampshire housing
finance authority somewhere uh around 20
000 units short of what we would
necessarily need going forward for
housing in the state um we need to be
able to bring whatever resources we can
to bear on all of those types of
projects across the spectrum of the
needs
thank you thank you madam chair
are there further questions uh
representative
all me
thank you
on i've been working in
housing in lebanon for
25 years now one of the thing with
bankers on mostly with bankers
on one of the things that we learned
through unfortunate experience
was that when we built
for
the approximately 10 above median income
in our area
uh
we ended up
on
with
housing
that that
helped our growing economy
but it was all for at least
10 percent above median income and it
left and
we were continuing to lose housing for
the people
below that level which is 60 of the
population and which also includes the
people that man our restaurants that man
our hospitals that uh on
everybody who is moving in
expected to be there
and
and every time we would build
at that level
we would see no impact on the 60 percent
and we would see
after a few months no impact because
on our economy is growing and in the
other parts of the state where the
seacoast particularly were just
just like a little piece of sea coast
you get that same kind of effect
so
what i'm
i'm really concerned with if there is
any
uh i'm concerned with there not being
any close tie with housing
new hampshire housing
which
was created to do this kind of thing i'm
not sure why that happened
and
i'd like to know specifically
for this capital grant program
could you make
a
a grant to a developer that was building
high income housing let's say five
thousand dollars a unit rent
required to pay back his costs
on
under
yes okay thank you representative and
yes i completely agree with you there is
this is a situation where
um
it's a it's an uphill battle in this
market right now to address availability
and affordability um whether it's
the national increase in housing costs
whether it's the supply chain challenges
that we're uh seeing
it is an all hands on deck type of
situation
and i think uh to your account i mean
the upper valley has got
a number of businesses that are that are
coming together to form a loan fund
for this very purpose um and to be able
to make investments in these types of
projects to address the issue that
you're talking about i will say that new
hampshire housing finance authority has
been very much part of the discussion um
in the development of this program
and in fact um under the 60 million
that is reserved for the individual
project
funding
50 million of it would be for this
particular program and 10 million of
those funds would go to new hampshire
housing finance authority to
implant into their existing programs
like
um whether it's a home program or it's
the affordable housing fund or whatever
the case might be so it is absolutely
all hands on deck type of situation
follow-up
yes with a question thank you yes uh but
the 50 million would uh could go
to
topping off for the developers that are
building the highest level of rental
housing in the state
i've been pretty clear we we have a very
strong
um and we will have a very strong
preference for what we refer to
generically as workforce housing
and again i'm trying to
walk a line here to be able to
build a program that has the flexibility
to address
a multitude of different needs
across the state and while you know
there might be
um extremely high uh costs in a
community like lebanon uh there may be
other more rural communities that um
that
that where sort of those types of income
restrictions might
might not be what they're looking to be
able to uh make an investment in so
uh i will i will continue to say though
that the projects that typically have
these gaps are the projects that will
already have affordability commitments
built into them
and
that is the real goal of the program
thank you it and the um i
i find it interesting where we're going
right here because this the uh
in the budget we certainly continued
with making sure that you got the 5
million a year to construct constructing
new hampshire we put a lot more money
into construction in new hampshire and
this hundred million
which i i think it's great that we chose
to use that part of opera money um where
we don't have the strings
attached from the federal government
because one of the things that i see was
picked up here and i certainly fought
for it is the fact that we're going to
work with communities that will get
applications through in six months
because isn't that the plan that we want
these to start to happen in a way
instead of fighting our local
communities
now we're proposing let's work with them
i think that's the way to do this i mean
we certainly have communities that don't
want to work with us on developing we're
basically saying to the communities that
do want to work with us team up with
developers locally and let's get started
i think the interesting part is that
you're going to start with non-profits
and you're going to
do that for the first couple of rounds
applications my only concern is we're
appropriating 100 million dollars right
now
and what i'm hearing and this i'm just
trying to find out because you did this
with gopher you had to reallocate
several times because the money didn't
get spent under the time period that it
had to be
i'm just concerned that just the calls
i'm getting on transformers
you know in the state of new hampshire
are stopping development today
i mean 60 weeks for someone that's
permitted and ready to make the purchase
for the transformers that's how long
it's going to take for them to work with
the electric company either of the two
big ones that i've talked to so far
and
i'm concerned that the 2026 deadline is
gonna at some point be affected and this
is a lot of money yeah is there some
point where you're going to start to
make decisions
to come back and talk about shifting
this yeah um yes all good point center i
think um you know without question
as i mentioned earlier developing any
type of housing right now in new
hampshire is an uphill battle for many
of the reasons that you've described
whether it's transformers whether it's
refrigerators whether it's all wood
products whatever the building
construction needs are
in addition to the sometimes
inability to find those products there's
also a cost component and again that's
the type of thing that we're looking to
impart be able to address to move these
projects forward to the extent that the
funding is available with regard to your
other question
um yeah i think i mentioned earlier that
we are having a deadline of the program
deadline would be the
in a year so june of 2023 so well before
our obligation deadline of 2024
uh that gives us both the opportunity to
work with projects um in order to um you
know identify and to accommodate for any
of the types of things that you're
describing but also gives us an
opportunity to see where the funding is
at that point and then make any
decisions that we would need to from
there this is as you'll as you know
an accept and expend request so
it doesn't mean that we are going to
actually that we will spend all 100
million but i have every expectation uh
given the state of the marketplace in
new hampshire right now that we are
going to get as close to that as we
possibly can
i'm sure you have that expectation yes
sir
i think on this committee we all have
things that constituents are asking for
us to fund right about now you mentioned
1500 units in the pipeline one of the
things that came up earlier in
discussing this
was
the dates where developers could use
this money if they're already in the
permitting process
and have been through planning board can
they get involved in this program yes
okay and does that have a look back
period to any point in time well we
would at this point uh what we would do
is probably have for the main program uh
the date of the governor's state of the
state address february 18th i believe
that was that the permits would have to
be applied for after that point
okay
and and and just something
this is going to be a question
um
not a chairwoman but
i think the public
the communities have to look at this
in a way that can tie to a lot of things
that are going on in the state but this
ten thousand dollars per unit
um that a municipality can get if
they're bringing units into their
communities
would be a great start to tying to all
these water projects that we're doing in
this state
because we're at this point trying to
tie together about a third coming from
the communities and the other two thirds
this is a great opportunity
as developers are working with
communities to cooperate and when
communities are saying we can't come up
with the money um you know 50 units
brings you 500 000
um that's 150 000 a project that you
could tie into so i see that it could be
a plus here but i i guess what i'd be
asking
um and this is my final question is it
possible on that june 23rd
that you report back to this committee
where we are with the money because i do
think there's places that could be
shifted to that could react quicker
certainly and i'd be willing to do it
even prior to that you know as we as i'm
a kind of a regular here these days i'd
be happy to give you updates as we go
through the program um and once it
initiates
are there
thank you madam chair
who's going to administer this if i if i
know a developer that might be
interested where where did that
developer go to knock on the door and
say
i'm interested the administration
program will happen at the department of
business and economic affairs
but any of our partners that we work
with in the housing space are going to
be part of the
the day-to-day operation of the program
like the new hampshire housing authority
yes sir okay thank you
representative
all right
senator d'alessandro thank you madam
chairman just two questions uh taylor
taylor how do you address the concerns
of the disability community that they're
going to be they're not going to be
positively affected by this i think
that's that's a concern how do you
address that and secondly the
municipalities receiving uh 40 million
don't you think that that there's some
concern from the municipalities that
this split
is uh
is not fair for them that they could do
a better job if you
uh
allocated more of your resources in
their direct in their direction so the
disabled situation and the way you
allocated the funds those two questions
please yes sir so on the municipal
component uh you know again these are
funds that are designed as senator morse
pointed out to help
incentivize communities that want to
participate
in
some level of development in their
community to
to receive funding that may be
the funds
the new project might impact the
community in some way they might want to
use those funds to put the the funding
back into the project whether it's for
infrastructure whatever the case might
be
and it is really aimed at the issue that
we have which is
we could um have all of this money but
if we don't have any communities that
are willing to um you know use their
zoning laws or
participate in the us in building
communities and helping their local
economies um there's no no way we can
spend that resource and so it's a
necessary component here so whether it's
the per unit piece or whether it's
helping them um review and plan for
their zoning regulations
or the demolition component
i think that that is a
a worthy investment in an overall
strategy to try to again accelerate with
one-time money within within a very
specific window of time
uh the maximum number of units that we
can
further question
well the
people are going to gravitate to the
urban areas and that's where
the
rehab could take place i mean i i see
many uh buildings in the area that i
represent with the with the uh the red
cross uh
which calls for demolition and that
that's i think the reason why
municipalities think that they should
get
more uh more money available to them and
uh that that's going to be a a a key
issue all the way around
the the vacancy rate obviously is the
minimus
so the the deed the deed has manifested
itself and so
but there's the second question i think
the disability situation we have
disability housing in manchester in uh
in years it's been it's been run by
crotchet mountain
uh and uh there's a definite need uh for
disability housing and how's that going
to be affected by this this plan that
you have in place and the municipalities
obviously would be the place where
disability housing would be most
effective because of the abilities that
are available to disabled
yes sir again i think
the the way to think of this program is
that it is one that is another tool in
the toolbox for people that are
developing housing of all types in the
state of new hampshire there are other
types of funding that are continue to be
available
for a multitude of different programs
through new hampshire housing or cdfa or
others i would hope that by continuing
to address the overall vacancy rate
program problem and the supply of
housing in the state that that will have
a ripple effect across
representative almi
thank you i i've got two questions one
of them is are you absolutely sure we
can meet the revenue replacement
criterion when the federal government
starts auditing yes ma'am
100 percent okay
on and the other one
is when we
uh
does the per unit grant program
uh also have this restriction that the
permit has to have been asked for in
february 22 which
or later which would mean that
they
can't possibly get anything out of this
uh start
start on
working on the project until september
um
my initial action is that it would be
but i i
your point is well taken we'll have when
we get to the point of
sort of doing the final rules on this
i'll take a a second look at that man
but you you make a good point yeah i'd
i'd like to uh mention
on we have a 400
unit permitted building that is supposed
to provide housing for the people mostly
that are going to be
on hired anew by uh dartmouth hitchcock
now hitchcock health or
dartmouth health uh
and on if
and that is stalled at this point and
they're being very close-mouthed about
it but originally they said it was
because
they could not get a contractor to start
working for four years to come which
means they're dumping
400 people into our housing market all
at once
and uh they're trying to do something
about it but
on
if
on i believe
so i'm i'm personally interested
in this so that lebanon doesn't end up
losing
every house we had that people could
live in that were under
mark uh
senator morris yeah i just want to point
out that
the thought of starting a program like
this
when we started talking to the governor
about it
was because of dartmouth
senator hood who's over there was the
first person i called because i saw a
business teaming up with a developer
and that's where this concept started to
evolve and then the governor took it a
hundred miles further but um that's what
this was all about trying to get people
to get creative in this state and i
think they've done a good job i think
this needs more work like anything else
but
and i can assure you on the revenue side
there's probably double that number
available in new hampshire
so okay
senator rosenwald
thank you madam chair we've been talking
about affordable
housing but a few minutes ago you said
it was your intention that
we use this money to invest in workforce
housing
those two things are different
in new hampshire law so
what is this
what is the commitment of this fund to
affordable housing which is the issue
being raised by the disability community
versus
workforce housing which speaks to a
higher income level
um well as you know senator the
linguistics of affordable workforce
housing are um are constantly in motion
um again i the the program that we're
that we're proposing today would be able
to invest in uh programs that have
affordability requirements in place now
those requirements
take a different form depending on the
program that is used is being used to
fund the
the the project so again if we were
using low-income housing tax credit
program that would have a different
affordability requirement or commitment
built into it than a program that might
use the community development block
grant program so
while we're not necessarily stating a
specific level
uh that you know you have to meet this
particular
threshold in order to be funded to the
program what we're saying is that we
want to be able to invest in all of
those types of programs and not
necessarily
change the subs the underlying subsidy
requirements that are in place for any
particular project so again it's the
flexibility piece this being a separate
tool
not the exclusive tool that is important
are there further questions
i know you've talked about
getting the rules getting the program
established when do you think that's
going to happen
well our goal right now is to have this
program be available by june of this
year okay so that means you'll have
whatever
people need to know about it to apply
yes it may yeah okay so we're looking at
june
yeah i am i'm writing it down okay
there's a a lot of i'll tell you there's
a lot of interest in this program from
people that i have heard from and uh
that's been one of the major questions
so
um
could i have a motion to accept move the
item okay uh senator daniels and senator
morris
roll call on 22-150 representative
edwards yes to 150 representative
emerick says yes representative earth
yes
uh senator daniels yes senator morris
yes senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
no
representative umberger yes
fis-22-150 passes on a vote of eight to
two
uh don't go too far
no you're gonna come back aren't you
maybe not
okay he'll be in the hallway all right
madam chair
madam chair yes
it sounded like you're asking for
something to be written and delivered to
us in june
could could we ask that they uh include
a section on what we're going to do to
make sure there's a full and open uh
competition for these grants and and i
when you're dealing with 100 million
dollars just uh curious to i'm just
interested in making sure that this is a
fair process and not a favored process
so
okay
no problem right
okay so um
we'll
see what happens in june
okay now we move on to
fis22151
department of health and human services
you know
actually could we take a five minute
okay thank you
oh tab
my only question is where are you going
to find these 21 people
i know that mr arlinghaus will
come to grips with that for us in a
little bit
so
go ahead
so seven of
only seven of the positions will not be
filled with existing hampstead employees
so all of the rest of the 21 will be
filled with existing employees of
hampstead hospital
so we only need to recruit for seven and
uh i agree i
expect that we'll be working with
administrative services trying to fill
those positions i also think there are
some advantages to the positions being
in the southern tier of the state it
does draw a different population than
okay
okay i i have one other question
um
what
are you anticipating the effect on the
budget will be in
sure and i forgot to state my name again
for the record karen lucas chief
financial officer hhs
uh the
the effect on the on the 2425 budget is
still being determined
so if it was based solely on this item
then i would say that the request would
be for nine million dollars a year in
general funds but what we don't know
because we're not operating the facility
yet is what the actual revenues will be
so what will class
revenue class 009 look like when we're
actually operating the budget and i
think fortunately
we will have a little time it probably
won't be until the house or potentially
even the senate phase before we have a
better idea
so it the agency budget probably will
look a lot like this
but the uh we'll be able to adjust that
in later phases as we get a better sense
of what the revenue actually is the
other thing i just want to mention about
this fiscal item is this is a 12 month
fiscal item with the exception of one
class line class line 12 which is
half of the anticipated budget because
those positions are budgeted in the
purchase item that we came with a couple
weeks ago the other reason i wanted to
mention that this is a 12-month budget
is that the department may be back with
an additional item
if the the close happens uh prior to 6
30. we the reason that we are doing it
this way is one we wanted to get an item
forward to you because we need to bring
a contract forward for the contractor as
soon as possible and two
we wanted the picture to be 12 months so
we may see a smaller item come back from
the department um a little later okay
thank you
uh could i have a motion please
i'd move the item thank you do i have a
second second senator guida
will the clerk please call the roll
roll call for 22 152 representative
edwards yes to 152 representative henry
both yes representative irf yes
representative almi yes senator daniels
yes senator morse
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes madam chair the vote is ten
to zero a vote being ten to zero fis-22
passes
and this is also department of health
and human services
fis22123
okay you didn't change your name since
we talked
are there any questions that anyone has
on this item
uh seeing none could i have a motion to
approve
thank you second
will the clerk please call the rule
we'll call for 22 123 representative
edwards yes to 123. representative
emerick says yes representative erf yes
representative all me yes senator
daniels yes senator morse yes senator
gaida yes senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yes representative umberger
yes madam sure the vote is ten to zero
thank you
fis 22 123
uh passes on a vote of 10 to zero
uh
okay
uh before everyone leaves today
what's the last name
what's your last name now
blank
okay before everyone leaves um
thank karen
rounds lucas
for all of her work as uh within the
next month she will be leaving state
employment
and i think that uh
the state is going to miss her a great
deal and
i wanted to
personally
thank you for all that you've done for
the fiscal committee
as well as the house and senate finance
yes
you certainly mean
thank you madam chair uh
i've been uh working with uh the former
miss rounds
uh for uh uh for a number of years and
and i must say i was gonna beat her up
badly today on an issue
seeing that was her last her last time
i
i still think the numbers are squashy
roundsy
but but i'll uh
i'll support you uh
i don't i don't think anyone uh has
spent more time and effort over at hhs
than than karen rounds uh
i know i'm on the phone to her uh
constantly uh trying to get answers and
and she's always there and working hard
to deliver uh
one of our problems is retention in
state government and if we don't start
retaining people like karen rounds and
others
we're going to be in big trouble
for that uh you know i
i i sincerely sincerely worry about our
future i wish you nothing but the best
in your future karen but i want to say
uh no one has has done more to assist me
in individual than you have
with regard to problems i had with hhs
so thank you very much for your service
and uh god speed good good health and
good job and
damn it you doubled your pay
that's neither here nor there okay
thank you madam chip you're quite
welcome
what was the last name kit
lucas lucas
miss lucas will be back to uh talk to us
um
okay moving on to
fis22133
good afternoon madam chair steve lavoy
director of administration for the
department of safety and with me is mark
doyle the director of the
division of emergency services and
communications
seeing none could i have a motion to
approve
senator rosenwald senator daniels okay
thank you
roll call for 22 133 representative
edwards yes to 133 representative amrex
yes representative earth yes
representative almi yes
senator daniels yes senator morse yes
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes man i'm sure
the vote is 10 to zero
thank you the vote being 10 to zero
fis 22 134
one sorry 133 passes
we now turn to thank you now turn to fis
new hampshire liquor commission this is
under tab
11.
i have a motion to table from
senator d'alessandro
and a
second from
senator rosenwald
okay
um is there a discussion around
unfortunately no
okay
uh will the clerk call the roll to table
please
table motion for 22 134 representative
edwards
uh no to table
sam enriquez yes representative erf yes
representative all me
senator daniels yes
senator morse yes senator gaida no
senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yes
representative umbrer yes
fis
madam chair the voters eight to two
the vote being eight to two the
fis22134
is tabled
the judicial branch
welcome back
are there any questions for the chief
justice
uh
i have one i just want to make sure
remaining marital master
is that what you're asking no you're
talking about converting two existing
vacant full-time marital master
positions and my question is were those
funded in the budget
are there any other questions
seeing none could i have a motion to
approve
so both
thank you senator d'allesandro second by
will the clerk please call the roll
roll call of 22-147
yes to 1.7
everybody's yes representative erf yes
representative almi yes senator daniels
yes
on a vote of 10 to 0 fis 22 147 passes
thank you very much madam chair
okay now turning to
sorry
tab 13 item number
i'm having trouble with my two eyes uh
what fis fis-22143
seeing none could i have a motion to
approve
thank you
second by representative earth
will the clerk please call the roll
roll call for 221
right
representative edwards uh yes 143
representatives representative erf yes
representative
yes
senator daniels yes senator morse
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger
yes man i'm sure the vote is ten to zero
on a vote of ten to zero fis-22
143 passes
we now move to
tab 14
fis
good afternoon good afternoon for the
record um i'm matt henry yeah for the
record you need to speak into the mic
thank you man
i'm matt henry director administrative
services
thank you
good afternoon i'm kim mckay i'm the
commander at the veterans home
well welcome thank you both of you are
seeing none could i have a motion move
the item senator daniels second second
will the clerk call the roll
we'll call for 22132 representative
edwards
votes yes representative erf yes
representative almi
senator daniels yes senator morse
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
man i'm sure the vote is ten to zero
vote being ten to zero fis 22 132
passes
thank you very much
uh we'll now move to tab 15
fis 22
the request from the board of tax and
would you please introduce yourselves
good afternoon madam chair my name is
michelle lebron i'm the chair of the
board of tax and land appeals
good afternoon my name is ann stellmack
i'm the clerk of the board of tax and
land appeals
thank you are there any questions
uh represent edwards
uh thank you madam chair um
so so this looks like it's uh an attempt
to go ahead and
contract out a review appraiser rather
than using in-house talent
that's the way i read it but is that is
that accurate and what's going to be the
net effect of this year over year
it's somewhat accurate
we've had a vacancy in that position for
over a year now and have not been able
to fill it
so it's an attempt to try
and get some qualified people through
contracts
to do some of the role that role said
are necessary for the board to function
um
represent army
you madam chair on i know we've got a
major shortage of qualified assessors in
this state now
and it's getting worse and
are you going to have to contract from
out of state from people that
wouldn't know our systems
we are hoping that we will not have to
because we we think they should be
qualified and know this state in order
to
function in the in the way that they
should
are there any further questions
could i have a motion please
thank you senator d'alessandro second
okay
uh will the clerk call the roll
roll call 22142 representative edwards
yes to 142 representative enrique voces
representative erf yes representative
almi
senator daniels yes senator morse
senator gaida
senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yes representative umberger
yes man i'm sure the vote is 10-0 thank
you on a vote of 10-0 fis 22-142
passes
thank you very much you're quite welcome
okay i now turn to
uh
tab
which is a late item from
uh
thank you would you please introduce
yourselves madam chairman um my name is
scott mason i'm the executive director
of fish and game to my right is
i'm ted diers i'm with des okay thank
you very much
uh the lady handing out the
we're handing out two reports one is a
governor's commission that was
commissioned to look at uh one specific
hatchery the new durham hatchery and
then also a report we did for the
governor's office
um which gives kind of a pictorial
vision and uh some data points on the
current um
the current hatchery system as a whole
okay thank you
uh does anyone have a question for
representative edwards uh this is
tangential from earlier conversation um
how many drones does fish and games own
and how many do you intend to buy in the
next two three years you have any idea
drones drones
um i
i'm not sure i have no idea i'm happy to
look into it though uh
please do because
earlier uh we just approved funding to
buy two more for the state 24.
24 which is more than two yeah so okay
are there any further questions
uh
senator rosenwald thank you
um
this well two questions if i could this
is not going to affect the hatchery in
nashua is that correct no ma'am nashua
is actually a federal hatchery that's
not
run by the state of new hampshire thank
you my second question is
um
i i noticed that
next week on the floor the senate is
being asked to eliminate the definition
of brook trout
yes ma'am are we going to be stocking
fish formally known as brook trout or
what what kind of trout
um are you talking well we'll
we raise
brook trout uh well we raise the easton
brook trout we also raise the brown
trout we also raise rainbow trout and
also landlocked salmon in our hatcheries
right now the landlocked salmon has
historically been raised at the new
durham hatchery and currently they start
at the the federal uh hatchery has been
working with us and they're they start
there and most of them will stay there
and then some come to new hampton for
finishing before we stalk them in the
lakes
are there any further questions
senator d'alessandro thank you madam
champ
mr director great to see you uh
we had a quick conversation outside but
i wish you'd share some of the details
with the members of the committee
the condition of the hatcheries that we
have right now
the cost to get those up to speed
and the decision-making process that
will go into what we save and what we
don't okay
um when we
started down the path at the new durham
hatchery one of the one of the ideas
that came up
um
is we're either going to be forced to
spend a lot of money on basically
sewer treatment plants to attach to
these hatcheries at some point
the other option came up as a change of
management technique so right now most
of our hatcheries are run with uh you've
probably seen them raceways or flat
bottom tanks
so the a newer methodology are actually
they're they're a round tank they look
like our round tanks but they have a
cone at the bottom the water goes in at
an angle creating a certifical force in
the water
and that forces all of the solids to the
it's a lot cheaper for us to remove
phosphorus while it's
whether it be spent feed or fish feces
than it is once that phosphorus starts
breaking down
and um
and then it's a chemical that we have to
remove
so as we looked at the problems we're
having environmentally it became obvious
that it would behoove us to upgrade our
hatcheries that we have
the condition of the hatcheries that
report that we sent around on on the
report we gave the governor on the
hatcheries you will see
their hatcheries are old the newest one
we have is at milford it's about 50
years old uh our next one is 75 the next
one is 90 and then we have three over
100 years old
and through time you know we've we've
done maintenance
but we probably haven't kept up at to
the level that we needed to to keep
these things going indefinitely and it
is time to you know between the issue of
the maintenance and the issue of trying
to improve the environmental footprint
of the hatcheries and reduce the
the phosphorus that we're releasing into
the streams
thank you are there any
follow-up just just
it
we talked about it we're talking about
an investment but we can't
or can we we can't save all of them can
we
um
it would be expensive we are we're we
are doing a study right now the entire
system um and we will be looking at
whether we can condense our operations
down i think we can
but we're not going to be making any
decisions until we finish up that study
as far as what the total number exactly
where they'll be what we'll start with
these construction projects are the
hatcheries that we know we're going to
be continuing with and that we can get
done as you're all well aware the two
issues the the the the two stumbling
blocks or pinch points that we have with
opera you know we have to have the the
funds in place by the end of 24 and we
have to have them spent by the end of
26.
and we just felt that by the time we got
done the entire study we would not be
able to you know complete the project by
the end of 26th so we're going to try to
move ahead uh with two of our hatcheries
and then we will come back probably
before capital budget
did you have a follow-up yes so
what effect will that have would stocky
uh as the goal is
is to hopefully maintain
um
production throughout um construction
we may get in a pinch where we're to
have to cut back temporarily during you
know during construction but
um
most of our hatcheries actually have
quite a bit of land so the concept that
we're trying to trying to look at is can
we set over and build a new facility
while the old facility's still being run
and then
you know turn the water on to the new
facility and when it's time for the you
thank you are there any further
questions
seeing none could i have a motion please
move the item thank you senator gaida do
i have a second
sec seconded by senator d'alessandro
will the clerk please call the roll
we'll call on 22 153
representative edwards
yes to 153.
hamrick votes yes representative irf yes
representative almi
yes
senator daniels yes senator morse
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes represent
umberger yes man i'm sure the vote is
ten to zero
the vote being ten to zero
22-156 passes
thank you very much
okay we now move to the informational
items are there any questions
on any of
okay seeing none
call up health and human services who's
going to
give us a little bit of an update on
arpa
and you have
at your seat
a sheet that looks a sheet that looks
yeah
great
first of all thank you i certainly
appreciate all of the kind words um and
i probably can't say much more than that
without tears coming so i'm just gonna
stick with that so thank you it's only
because you changed your name
[Laughter]
you know just creating a little
confusion um
alessandro would tell you that that's
just part of what i do create a little
bit of confusion uh
so this document that i provided i know
the chair asked for a presentation and
this is not a presentation per se and i
want to explain
why and then talk about um how i'd like
to move forward with it or how the
department will move forward with it
um
we have about 75 plus grants that have
come to the department directly in arpa
funding that are not through a gopher
so none of what is reported here are
grants that came through gopher
as you all know i don't like to reinvent
the wheels so what i did is we started
with uh the document that the lba has
created for all funds that have been
accepted either through the governor's
emergency powers or through your
committee
and
a governor governor and council asked
for an update on spending about a month
and a half ago
um and so we took the lba's document and
added a spending column and that is what
we provided to governor and council
you'll note that the date on this is as
of january 13th and that is why because
i used that same document i provided to
governor and council
what i did for your committee is then
also have
my staff add a fiscal narrative column
to go through
what each of them are and
then you'll be get a sense of what the
spending has been on
and i think what makes the most sense is
to
give you all some time to digest this i
know that this was just given to you
this morning and then
ask the department to present on um
grants of interest things that you're
interested in understanding better what
the money was spent on or what it will
be spent on
just one caveat the expended column is
truly expended so if it's been
encumbered meaning that there is a
contract already in place that governor
and council is approved for spending
those funds that is not represented in
that column it is only if we've paid the
vendor so you may see a couple that you
read the description you say why they've
not spent that money it's likely just we
have not been billed yet by the vendor
um so that is just something to keep in
mind
but that uh that was how i decided to
approach it rather than creating a 75
slide powerpoint and sitting here for an
hour and a half walking you through each
of them and having each director come up
i thought you might appreciate having um
you know a more um
a more succinct approach to the things
representative edwards
so um so you're right i've i've i've not
digested this document yet but so i'll
just ask my standard question which is
is there a summary of all of the
disparate it requests so that we
understand just in a kind of a nutshell
all the moving parts under the i.t
upgrades
so i that is was not specifically called
out on this document if that's something
you're interested in that is something
we can prepare for you and tell you
which of these grants uh are being used
for it projects
well and it's not just that the full
grant is being used for an i.t project
as i recall a few of them uh the it was
embedded within a grant and so um so the
idea of of tracking it gets to be a
little bit more complicated because it's
not
at the top level it's buried within so
so just just so that i'm consistent i'm
i'm going to say that i've been
concerned
that on the good side of things you now
have money to do all the i.t refresh
that we know of but i just am concerned
that we're not able to have visibility
into them as a set of i.t projects
so um
so i don't know how to form that in a
request other than to continue to say i
at some point i i would really like to
see what the i.t portfolio looks like
i think in in the interest of my
favorite term not in reinventing the
wheel you had suggested that you were
going to bring a request forward to the
health and human services committee
which uh
director weeders attends on a regular
basis and so that's probably the better
venue for that question and getting that
information sort of wholesale rather
than piecing out what's in these arpa
grants and then you want to know the
bigger picture um because i think that
would create some double work for us i i
hate double work um i i
i've asked the chairman of hhs oversight
to schedule this particular
topic
i don't know how mr weeders would do it
without your help or whoever is
replacing you you can't be replaced but
whoever whoever it is and you're in your
seat um so
uh but okay i i hear you and i i
certainly appreciate you saying that and
um
you're giving me an opportunity to just
say one thing that's very important to
me i am truly just a face in this
department every piece of information
you've received is from somebody on my
staff and i have seen every single one
of them grow exponentially in the past
four years and so i am entirely
confident that you're gonna still
receive good information you'll just see
a different face here
and and i have to say to that that uh
your leadership i think is critical
because i've sensed nothing but
integrity coming from you and your staff
and that's a that's a personal attribute
that has been passed on to the staff and
and i'm gonna hopefully not miss that
you will not i'm certain of it
senator rosenwald thank you
um would you be able to email this
document so that we could blow it up and
search it yes i thought of you
immediately when i printed it this
morning i'm like senator roosevelt's
gonna be so mad about my small type
again
yes i will have it sent over to my king
thank you chair
okay just in case you know we're we're
uh
we're going to ask that uh
the department reformat the um
[Music]
uh dashboard
yes so actually that is a project that
the department has been working on um i
have been working on that project with
uh mary kalise who many of you know is
the deputy cfo and nathan white who's
the director of contracts uh and we have
a follow-up meeting
with this senior executive team at the
department next week uh so i do
anticipate that you will see a draft of
that dashboard uh towards the end of the
fiscal year but we are actively working
on that and
making a much nicer and easier to read
dashboard yeah
the other thing is maybe you could get
rid of this font
and then that way they wouldn't be able
to use it so if if i understand
correctly
uh
the department would like us to read
through this
and figure out which of these projects
are ones that we're interested in yes
and that we should get that back to you
by when
[Laughter]
after may 5th no uh
no really truly whatever works for the
committee i'm happy to you know work
with the team to you know put together
like i said i think a powerpoint is
totally appropriate i just didn't want
to do 75 slides so um i suspect there
are certain grants that people are more
interested in than others
okay so um
if i task you to
have something to michael by may 5th
is that enough time or do we want more
time
okay may 5th it is
okay
thank you thank you very much oh yes let
me ask a question surely thank you yes
so you showed six billion dollars looks
like in total grant funding
so
um
i don't think i totaled last page on the
uh
yes but i think that's all the grants on
this document i don't think that's just
the grants that went to dhhs
okay so i shouldn't ask a question about
what the non-grant funding represents
what's on the on the very last page uh
no you could ask the lba that this is
that part is their document i just like
i said i tried to
keep it on in a format that you all have
seen before to try to make it a little
bit easier but um the ones that don't
have an amount
expended or a fiscal narrative are not
okay so we all have a task
and uh
then hhs will have a task so
okay and if you don't mind i'm we are
going to head out unless there was a
question that we should stay for the
audit item
okay all right thank you very much for
all your time all right thank you again
yep
okay
we now have um
[Music]
uh
des and uh they have provided
you need to turn the mic on ah thank you
there you go good afternoon madam chair
and members of the committee my name is
for the record my name is bob scott i'm
commissioner with the department of
environmental services i have with me
susan carlson the chief operating
officer for the department uh as the
chair mentioned you should have before
you
uh two documents uh one is
a uh
basically a verbal recitation of the
different programs that we've are we
that we are running uh
that apply to the 150 million dollars on
our grants uh that we've received
and the other table uh is
set of tables is
the status and the the offers that have
gone out to the different uh systems
both uh wastewater and drinking water
and uh
any case i will uh so this realification
both these documents when we're done
here we'll send those to you
electronically uh and my intent is to
briefly walk through the narrative
here
so
by way of backgrounds uh
our estimate not including water
contamination issues and
future growth
our understanding of the need for water
and wastewater infrastructure
uh work is in the for new hampshire's in
excess of two billion dollars
uh with that in mind we were very very
pleased to be able to uh use you know
last year you you were gracious enough
to allocate 150 million dollars in opera
funds to us
uh what we have had done at that time uh
and by way of background historically
uh we run uh this for clean water and
when i say clean water that's uh
waste water storm water and drinking
water state revolving loan program so
that's a annual uh program that we run
and with that we do a annual
solicitation for pre-applications uh so
anticipating that there would be arpa
funding coming
uh staff signaled to the the usual
parties if you will
that's a possib that's more likely we
will see that the opera funding
to be coming from so within that with
that in mind last june submittal
for
applications for these loans was in
excess of a billion dollars uh that we
received for applications and we use
that that that process
in the first round to to basically uh
augment the existing uh
process we have for awarding uh funds
for the state revolving loan fund so
what what what staff was able to do is
use the same criteria
uh you a lot of them the system sent uh
had applications into us and we were
able to send offer letters to them uh to
the extent good news you've gotten a
state revolving loan fund that you've
asked for
better news instead of this amount it's
going to be x amount alone and x amount
of uh arpa funding to go with that
once we ran out of the the amount of
money allocated for state revolving loan
fund offers
then there was
further uh
monies that were allocated for our
grants so those letters look to the
extent that uh obviously i'm
paraphrasing bad news sorry you didn't
qualify for an uh a srf loan this this
year however
you've been awarded a 20 grant for your
project for
for arpa
and if you're able to put the rest of
the project funding together you'll have
this monies so
and the reason why i mentioned offers so
uh
a couple items on this
so
we don't just write a check if you've
been awarded it's it's work that you
have to meet milestones uh understanding
that arpa
has very definitive guidelines and i
think we all agree we don't do not want
to be giving money back to the federal
government the money needs to be
obligated by the end of the 24 and the
project associated needs to be completed
uh by december 2026
so it's it's important also recognize
that we put on these offer letters we
put milestones in for instance often uh
town meeting is required to to do
approvals
and so it's it is possible as you look
through this list that some of these
projects don't happen they're not able
to meet the milestones that we put forth
and we'll be in a mode where we'll need
to reallocate if they haven't met them
else the uh
the milestones so that we can make sure
a deserving project is able to get done
and the money is not sent back to the
federal government
so with that if you look at the
the package uh
with the narrative
uh table one gives you an idea of the
monies that have been offered so far so
and i'll explain the different
categories here as we go through so that
the main category is what i just
described is is utilizing our our
existing state revolving loan fund
programs
both for wastewater treatment storm
water drinking water and development of
new water supplies
the arpa grants
associated with those range from 20 to
50 percent
we are doing another
set round of applications for that to do
the same type of thing and that that
will be uh the applications will be
received up to june 1st of 2022 so
that's a fairly typical thing we do so
that's on an ongoing thing
so that will add to the list that you
you see on the the first table
the other program we put together using
the arpa funds is we're calling it
assistance for disadvantaged communities
and this has to do with residential
owned communities manufacturing home
cooperatives for co-ops
so we have monies grant monies for them
they're typically not able to leverage
loans like some of the bigger systems so
this has been a big help we out of the
first solicitation
uh from last year for srf loans we were
able to pick eight projects that met the
criteria
uh we are we have a sec first
solicitation directly for these type of
communities with applications due on one
june 22 so we expect more for that
the the third category is planning and
long-term sustainability grants
uh so we have a category here for
you know as you may imagine especially
the wastewater systems but the drinking
water systems as well these things don't
don't come out of nowhere they require a
lot of a lot of planning up front to
make all the pieces work so we were able
to provide some funding for that
and the other part of that is we're
calling it system sustainability so
asset management which is
sounds easy but you'd be amazed at the
number of systems that don't know where
what their assets are where they are or
the condition of them so obviously if
we're going to be funding a project
that's pretty important for them to have
that kind of information uh so so we we
have long we have typically funded out
of srf uh that type of activity and we
will do that also and have been doing
that with the arpa funds
energy audits water
audits and a new thing is uh cyber
security uh work uh which i'll talk
about in a moment
so the the cyber security uh work uh is
where we are working with uh us
department of homeland security
uh we're recognizing that these systems
nationally and certainly within the
state too are vulnerable to cyber
security uh vulnerabilities
so we've worked with epa they have a
contractor in us department of homeland
security and we're offering free
assessments for
these systems once they have the
assessments done they basically get a
checklist of recommendations for things
to do
and for those systems we're offering
grants up to fifty thousand dollars for
for per drinking water system or a
wastewater system
uh so far we've received five
applications that may sound like not a
lot but again you have to get the the
assessment done first so that will be an
ongoing effort for us that's being
looked at nationally as a
as a best practice by the way
uh another area we're able to get at
with the arpa funding that we typically
haven't been able to do with srf money
because there's just so much demand is
flood risk uh so so funding projects for
flood resilience storm water management
planning and assessment work as well as
implementation so uh you know that
includes projects on the coast obviously
but also obviously the western part of
the state last year had a lot of flood
flood damage and that type of thing so
we're we're able to with this expanded
pot of money we're able to actually get
at some of the funding for those type of
projects also
and then unfortunately it seems like i
can't have any discussion without the
four-letter word of pfas
so we are also uh able to leverage some
of this money as a grant program
that leverages the loan program that the
legislature was able to do a few years
ago
they allowed us to bond up to 50 million
dollars
to fund pfas remediation for those
systems so we're able to to match some
of that money also
and the last category we're calling it
that we've been funding is we're calling
it strategically important water supply
projects
and so we've we so far funded for those
projects those are on the table also uh
one of them was the scoping project for
the fist hatcheries you just talked
about
and
excuse me my voice is failing um and one
is also to help the title londonderry
they are
the
largest concentration of private
drinking water wells in the state right
now that that have been addressed for
pfas contamination so we're working with
them on
some planting money on how to best best
scope out
hopefully a water system to replace
those drinking water wells that are
contaminated
so with that uh certainly happy to
answer any questions i realize it's late
in the day also
uh again our intent is to to send out uh
these materials also electronically
especially this one has a lot of links
on it you will note when you see that
our website is
basically talks about everything that
i've been talking about is on our
website
so with that i'd be happy to take
excuse me
senator morris yeah i'd just like to
point out so there's no surprises on the
house side uh the commissioner reminded
me when he came in today um we will have
to put money
um
to match the srf money that's coming
right now
to the state for 23
so i think it's 22 and 23 actually
so we'll be putting an amendment on
something and sending it over to the
house
so that we can take the additional money
that washington has right now on srf
okay
excuse me so
we put our srf money in in the budget
but because of the new money we have to
add to the srf is that so
in the chart that i've been
following that mike has
we actually have it on there and the srf
funding is on there
the additional srf funding so okay
well some things come with good news and
some things come with the only thing is
as we talk about who can have the money
that is for the poorer communities not
for
the wealthier community so there's a
couple things going on there so but it
does have a high level of forgiveness
with it so okay
that's great
are there
i i really i really appreciate this and
i think that
you have summed this up very well in
your um in in your presentation
oh i'm sorry senator gaida i'd just like
to request a couple of minutes with you
after we're done assuming we're done
fairly shortly thanks that's fine i'll
but this is uh this is the kind of thing
that uh i think it's important for us to
know how we're
spending this money
wherever it is so
seeing no further questions thank you
very much
and
how come did i miss that on here
no it was not on the agenda um you would
ask the commissioner to come back and
hi hi
i'm charlie arlinghaus i'm the
commissioner of administrative services
but maybe you knew that um
so i'm here to talk to you as much as
you want about vacancies um i passed out
i didn't pass out
mike did actually um but i handed it to
him um four sheets of paper which give
you a sense of what i think i want to
give you every month the sheet that says
vacancy rates for the state of new
hampshire
and then the total by department
um
page three is a list where we broke it
out based on some things people were
asking about
um the class 10s and the class 59s are
separate so you can understand both by
department etc how those look
um i think those charts are
self-explanatory um the page four i gave
you is is we've started looking trying
to do some data analysis on trends
and understand what's going on when it
started when it's stopping etc and this
is just a quarterly snapshot for you
when you look at the numbers at the
bottom you can see how they're growing
although they appear to tick down
0.1 percentage point in the last eight
days which i suppose is nice um but i
want to mention uh the chairman had a
specific question about
um class 59 positions and we've created
about 104
um i actually asked our data people to
do this is this is close but not exactly
the same thing probably because then
sometimes some positions aren't stood up
right away and there's so there's
probably an overlap issue but
since july 1st we've stood up about 106
positions and 77 of them are filled and
and that's i for yours for your question
about whether we're filling positions or
not whether we're taking care of them or
not um that's a more useful data point
than the um
185 of 407 positions are filled
um i want to mention a couple things are
we losing ground yeah we're losing
ground
our goal the whole reason as we started
this standing up a statewide recruitment
unit is to stop losing ground
and and i think that's gonna happen we
hired three very very good people
um congratulations yeah well we do what
we can yeah um so in fact one of them uh
behind me or probably behind joe i'm
gonna do this without turning around
cassie keene is our deputy commissioner
you know cassie laurie roos the director
of personnel but we hired kate uh
malavey who's over here um and she comes
to the state service from the military
so i'm gonna say nice things about her
or she could probably kill me um which
we're against um just broadly speaking
but kate is heading that unit um i'll be
meeting with her regularly i did on her
first day which was a week ago
um
and we're we're doing things for example
you know it's a week so i don't you know
don't expect every uh everything to turn
around in a day you know the queen mary
doesn't pivot it gradually
turns um but we did some work on we did
a uh an email blast to lna's you know
this is a this isn't brain surgery right
you get a list of the
lnas and uh from licensing and then you
email them and say do you know the
state's hiring and
we had uh we had 10 interviews within 24
hours and so it's little things like
that that this is going to happen
i i want you to understand that in in if
you look at the current fiscal year just
it's easy for us to look at the number
of vacant positions as a snapshot in
time oh my god we can't hire anybody
well i would tell you this we hired
we've hired in the state about 4 000
people
in the last nine months
and so and i i got at this i started
looking at my own department you know
some of those are from other agencies
about half right but we've hired 1900
ish 1911 i think don't hold me to that
um people from outside new hires or
rehires which is just a term for someone
who worked for the state six months ago
or 20 years ago but 1900 new people
coming in we have people leaving
and that's an issue and the goal is to
is to get that to change are
are people leaving in greater numbers
than they used to
preliminary look is that it doesn't look
like it um and i'm trying to compare
apples to apples which turns out to be
harder than you think
um but and so part of this is there's
going to be a lot of data analysis over
the next um
months going and i'm i'm actually going
to try to do a lot of that myself i sort
of like data
um and um and it seems like it'd be an
interesting thing to do and it makes it
easier for me to talk about when i've
actually looked at it directly um
but we hire a lot of people and and so
it's not that people aren't interested
in the state as an employer they still
are 2 000 people who didn't used to work
here do work here again
but we've lost ground in in recent time
but the idea is to is to is to push that
and turn it slowly and get there and i
think i think that's the point that
sometimes we fall back on
um we fall back on a narrative right
that you this is sort of a newspaper
level analogy or the not newspaper level
headline level right the you know hiring
impossible and in our heads we draw a
picture of
you know i post a position and no one
applies and nobody interviews and i
can't get anybody
i spend half my life interviewing every
final interview i've mentioned this year
before i'm i do usually cassie and i do
um and um
because i think it's important for the
culture of the department um but i feel
like i'm doing them all the time it's
not true it's a few a week but
there's a lot of hiring going on people
are posting positions regularly
obviously at 20 vacancy rates you post
positions a lot we get applicants we get
a lot of very good applicants i'm not
hiring mediocre people when they come to
the door i'm hiring very good people um
we often leave that interview um saying
not something like like they seem like
they might be okay but wow i really
liked her she was great
and um and i want a lot of that and
let's hope i'm right right that you know
she seemed great um but um
there's a lot of that going on but a big
piece of it is that there's a lot
there's a lot to do a high vacancy rate
does a couple things um gives you a lot
of opportunity to rebuild your team and
to do new things with your team
but it also means that that there's a
lot of work that goes on before
and there's a lot of work that goes into
that
and one of the i think one of the
hardest things for hiring managers i'm
trying to develop sympathies
for hiring managers is um
hiring is a job it's a lot of work
and it's particularly a lot of work in a
system like ours which involves a lot of
paperwork and things like that and i'm
not suggesting that a lot of it's not
important because we you know taxpayer
protections etc
but it's a lot of work and sometimes
you're thinking yourself i've got a job
i can barely keep up with
and now i got to devote
10 hours a week for a few weeks to doing
something that's not quote-unquote my
job but helps me do my job so there's a
lot of that and and i think a big piece
of what we're going to try to do is to
help people along with that and you know
we're not going to we're not we don't
have a statewide recruitment unit to
help with every position
but we have a recruitment unit to help
everybody and everybody get further down
the road and i think that's what's gonna
happen we really are trying to turn the
queen mary around not um
not to uh donuts in the parking lot
i think that works as an analogy yeah
are there any other questions uh
representative edwards
um thank you madam chair um
one one was the last time
our
uh public-facing
uh website the application uh when was
the last time it was updated
uh and and the genesis of this question
is about three years ago
i went and played around with the uh the
job from from the public's perspective
if i knew i wanted a job with the state
the search function was just horrible it
was the one of the worst websites i've
ever seen and so i talked to dennis
goulet about it and he said the good
news is that the application underneath
that
was free
so i suggested to him that we probably
want to spend some money so that we can
improve our public-facing
search engine so that they can find jobs
that they are qualified for so so back
to the question when was the last time
that software uh that faces the public
was updated do you know we're uh so
we're in the process of uh redoing it
regularly um as as you may know the the
governor had a very similar experience
in late 2017 early 2018
um
and expressed himself in fairly similar
terms terms from his playing around on
it and um i forget how he described his
assessment of the performance of it but
um
there's probably words i can't use
um so we've looked at that the the
latest iteration probably went went up
i'm going to say a year and a half ago
but don't hold me to that it might be it
might be just before covet or it might
be just in the beginning of covid that's
not to say that we updated and looked
pretty good we made some improvements to
it there are under there's underlying
functionality with the system that's
problematic um the the system as you
probably know are our our system is run
by infor our enterprise resource system
is run by infor and it was developed as
in sort of a hybrid fashion um the the
bid was run one 10 years ago 12 years
ago whenever 16 years ago joe maybe
by a company called lawson
and a lot of the underlying technology
comes from lawson which is a company
that infor bought and a lot of that
technology i think people call it the s3
side is
mediocre and it was a company that won
uh they were the low bidder
and uh somebody once said well you got
what you paid for
there's another side of it which is more
developed with infor infor has been
updating their product um we're uh we're
looking we've been meeting regularly
with dennis actually over the last
i don't know six eight weeks and and
i know cassie can shake her head behind
me if i have the timing wrong but we had
a big meeting to talk about what do we
do do we get a whole new system and and
keeping in mind that the job function is
integrated into the system for uh for
management reasons
um do we get a whole new system you know
we oracle and workday and everybody else
bids on it and how much does that cost
do we do nothing which is the state
approach of the 80s and 90s we did
nothing in ghrs and ifs eventually
disintegrated uh to the point where
nobody could fix them anymore
and we had to reprocure or do we do the
next iteration of infor which includes
moving from land-based to cloud-based
um and a significant upgrade which they
call cloud suite which is different from
being on the cloud i think that's where
we're going to land but it's an
expensive long proposition
that will improve things but we can't
wait for that to improve things
the application is mediocre or the
application process is mediocre for
example when i interview people i hate
it
when the so what happens is our our
managers give me
uh resumes to look at and i want a
resume i don't want our application and
that tells me something right that the
fact that i hate the state application
and it's the state application we do
means it's bad um so we're we're trying
to improve it some of it is written into
the rules and so we're in the process of
doing a rules upgrade i actually have a
have a very preliminary draft of
personnel rules upgrades and one of the
goals is to take
you know a lot of ways to do rules but
one of them is you specify every line
item and the rules will just decide you
know what's in box 12 what's in box 13
which i think is insane and we're trying
to get away from that if the
if the officer rules lets us
um and we're gonna so we're gonna change
our rules so we're gonna get there but a
big piece of recruitment is to make this
is to make it easier to apply one
um well first of all easier to find out
about job two easier to apply three
easier to certify for a job we've made
some significant progress in that some
some i think very important rule changes
that actually other states are adopting
now
um
and then easier for a manager to hire
you and get the
that processed so that you can get in
the door because everything that extends
the time i apply for three jobs
and um i get an offer from
you know deca in four days i'm not going
to wait a month for the state to get
back to me so
we've updated recently but we have a
did you want to follow up yes
very comprehensive answer glad to hear
that you have visibility of it because i
i do think one of the reasons we have
trouble hiring people is people can't
try to be hired very well so the other
part i just would ask you to keep your
eye on
is that a lot of our jobs were able to
offer a veteran's preference
and as i recall the application there
was no way to search
to say i'm a veteran tell me which jobs
are available for which a veteran would
have preference so so that was a
specific functionality that i thought
should be included but oh i'll look into
that i know i looked at veterans
preferences a while ago and i and i
don't remember the outcome i think when
it was originally developed it was it
was uh
the structure of the law was predicated
upon examination-based positions which
we have very few of anymore
um and so let me look into that
okay uh senator daniels thank you we're
seeing seeing numerous bills come
through the legislature and through this
committee numerous requests for
establishing new positions to what
extent is das approving
the establishment of new positions as
opposed to looking at the vacancies that
exist in changing those vacancies over
to
positions
that wouldn't would not establish new
ones
a couple things the the quick answer to
that is new positions are approved by
the legislature not by um not by
administrators so i have an
administrative function not a policy
function um so you approve positions um
i i don't i process them
um so that's one thing secondly
um the repurposing of vacant
vacant positions is a difficult thing
it's meant to be difficult right the the
budget is approved on a position basis
you approve the expenditure of money for
a specific purpose
you may hire 14 electricians you can't
say oh i got them to approve 14
electricians now i'm going to convert
them all to accountants
and and because that's a that becomes a
policy decision and i end up going
before committee and senator morris goes
oh i didn't say you could do that and
then i'm in trouble so
however um you know there are elements
of 21g that suggested that managers are
meant to manage that you're supposed to
run your department the way you're
supposed to manage it and um
and there's a reclassification process
that's outlined in the rules it's a
fairly cumbersome process and it and it
it anticipates you taking an individual
position
um
filling out paperwork to convert it but
our job as a uh as our regulatory
function personnel's regulatory function
is to look at the paperwork you you do
as a department let's say you're an
agency you do as an agency and make sure
that the position you're creating is
appropriately classified that based on
the job duties you outline that as an
administrator too it's not a
project manager for whatever the
classifications are and that you've
selected the appropriate pay range and
that when that paperwork is done it
meshes in the in the grid
it is not our role responsibility or
authority frankly to guess whether
that's a legitimate business need of
yours or not that is a discussion
between you as an agency head and the
legislature and the governor
um our job is merely to uh is a
ministerial function as opposed to a um
uh approval function i don't have policy
are there any further questions
i do have one comment um
mr bouchard what makes you think you can
retire
i mean i had this discussion once
already today
but um
i would just uh simply like to
congratulate you for your years of
service
and everything that you have done
to help das over the years
and
i i know that i'm appreciative of it and
i'm sure the other folks that are still
here are so we wish you the best of luck
in retirement
and will you be back one more time
i didn't think so
okay yes uh senator d'alessandro
first of all thank you madam chair and
uh i know it's been a long meeting but
uh
you know i i say off over and over i say
over and over again that life's all
about relationships and i i think the
relationship that all of us have with
joey bouchard
is something very very very special
i've been around here joey for 50 years
so uh
i haven't met many people here
that hit the high standard you do
uh you're a remarkable guy
great worker but more important than
that
you're you're a human being who has
great concerns for everybody that you
serve and i can't say that with with
greater enthusiasm and this just greater
significance
uh if we could do a model of joey
bouchard would we'd be way ahead in
terms of state employees let me tell you
that so joey thanks for everything
you've done for me and for this date uh
and uh
i i say it truly even though you're from
maine
and the maniacs are tough
uh
you're just a great great american joe
and and thank you for all you thank you
for all your i thank you for all you've
done truly appreciate it thank you
[Applause]
is there
anything else to come before the fiscal
committee just the date of the next
meeting
whatever the third
uh may 20th is the third friday okay
does that work
works for me
okay okay thank you
a lot of stuff to carry back
happy easter we should have oh yeah
you